don't like Minority Report and asking
people removing their rights before they
commit a crime no so not removing their
rights before you send a crime it's
going to be taking away their access
just weapons that they can use to kill
people right or take a form they failed
any please well yeah because so far
they've committed crimes so what you're
proposing is looking for indicators that
someone might commit a violent crime
and removing their access to firearms
before they committed yes how is that
not Minority Report time for the latest
installment of changed my mind where we
rationalize our views on controversial
topics in context in full unedited as
always comment below your thoughts on
this videos topics or what subjects
you'd most like to see for future
installments this go-around we went to
UT Austin and cycled through as many
topics as time allotted except this time
there's a little twist there's gonna be
a twist today I'm not going to be
talking with anyone you guys are gonna
be talking amongst each other now the
Dean of Student Activities wasn't very
fond of this new approach however and we
immediately were warned that our permit
would be revoked so uh little little
hiccup here we're trying to make sure
that this is okay to go the Dean of the
Student Activities may pull our permit
to be here if two students come up and
converse apparently it's only okay if I
sit down and talk with somebody but it's
a problem if you both sit down and talk
with each other we're going to see if we
can work it out if not we're gonna have
to change the format and hopefully do
something
okay let's see if we could do that to
start with because of some permit issues
some miscommunications we cannot have
both students sit down so we kind of
have to jerry-rig it we'll have one
person sit here and then we'll have some
one person behind the rope
and they're going to have this
conversation right now to rationalize
their positions with a workaround in
place we start it up and right away we
had a good run of productive civil
dialogue between students if you want to
manifest your own identity or your own
way of being perceived or perceiving
yourself I think you should be able to
do that without people saying that it's
not natural I could go around wearing a
dress if that's what I particularly
wanted but are you still a boy then
because you have a penis
I don't sue Stephen oh that's a good
thing or bad thing
I thought you ate 50 pounds course as
always we had our share of detractors
the dialogue then safety comes and fear
goes out I'm uncomfortable because
students don't feel safe on their own
camp
what what are you what did he say hold
on cause listen pause cause listen okay
it's very hard for us to get permits
right now we're trying to get two
students to have a discussion that's
civil from wildly differing viewpoints
I think that's happened thus far even
though you disagree it's been pretty
respectful the only person to shout out
someone is a [ __ ] idiot is you just
do me a favor do me a favor don't be an
ass of your whole life okay yeah let's
bring him up here so we did yeah
definitely not gonna change anybody's
mind I just want to talk on the mic
honestly okay so you wanted to waste
people's time
I mean you waste a lot of people's time
on YouTube really yeah I forced people
to watch me on YouTube nobody forced
with you but a lot of people use your
videos as evidence for why they're right
when like it's literally just circular
arguing the show yeah I know what that
feels like nice you go watch yours all
right thanks man now I won't lie this
installment was harder for me as I had
to bite my tongue all day like you asked
but how many genders there are we don't
need to define them there can be an
infinite number of genders is all about
what you define that doesn't mean I'm a
unicorn right obviously exists life is
literally a concept as always subscribed
at the notification Bell comment below
and most importantly join my club at
ladder with CARICOM slash mug club to
support segments like these not only do
you get access to daily exclusive shows
not seen on youtube but it's the only
way for this kind of content to continue
on with the show meet Michael and Sean
to students on opposing sides of the
Second Amendment
both were chomping at the bit to get in
on any of our topics of the day
which isn't usually a good sign but we
hoped for the best
I'm worried about you coming up I'm
really worried about you coming up like
you're something tell me because you
know when someone comes up with
jazzed up if you're doesn't go very well
can you do you think you got reasonable
arguments here that you can present and
you're not going to name call and I
think you're ready is this guy seems
pretty sharp too you're gonna be going
you're gonna be going up just close up
on YouTube with a really sharp guy you
feel qualified to the second amendment
thing okay right now this is going to be
on the second amendment
I'm pro-gun changed my mind and we will
let them go ahead and do it okay what's
your name sir Michael Michael come here
and have a seat sir
all right your name sir is Sean Sean
nice to meet you Sean Michael okay so uh
Michael you're familiar with the segment
how it works
state your position in the affirmative
and allow Sean to change your mind so
Sean I feel that the Second Amendment in
the United States is critically
important to both the security of the
nation as well as the historical culture
of the United States and I feel that a
lot of the measures taken or interest in
restricting the second method further
than it already is are generally
unfounded
sure and I'd welcome you change my mind
cool so let's first talk about like the
culture that it has within America so
you're saying that like oh the Second
Amendment critical because it's been
historically important but we can both
agree that the Second Amendment has been
pulled back as history's moved on in
order to like adjust with societal
changes right so like the Second
Amendment as it is today theoretically
can change tomorrow depending on what we
think is best for society the Second
Amendment as an amendment I mean this
can be yeah sure I just want to begin
here I don't get it should be though
okay but it can't be like rollback right
it could but I shouldn't okay you for
sure well I would argue adding
restrictions as more akin to adding
seatbelts into cars crashing into wildly
places but let's go ahead and talk about
what restrictions we shut out on so
would you agree that we should have more
background checks for example a screen
for mental illness um I think that a
screen for mental illness would be would
be rather well I will tell you that
there already is a federal background
check required about you but it's not
screaming mental illness correct it's
not looking at your medical history for
example um i am i understanding as it is
could you could you fill on
do I mean it's not I'll just say that
like the part of the platform currently
that the DNC is running on is plenty
adding on more background checks
screening for different members I would
say actually it does have you okay Baba
I only this is important just because he
asked and you just said it's true but
it's what you see man it's awesome look
into people's medical history past
medical history correct sure not
something as extensive is looking into
somewhat private maximum advocating is
looking at the past medical history
that's what the current platform is was
looking at history of mental illness and
screening for that would you agree
that's reasonable I would agree that
that's reasonable okay but if follow-up
question as to that is what did one
mental illnesses would constitute not
allowing people that have guns and which
ones wouldn't because then you again in
the dicey territory of well you don't
mean that that would be up to I mean
obviously that would be up to
legislators an individual implementation
and we see what would work best but like
for example if someone has like a
history of schizophrenia or a history of
paranoid delusion or a history of like I
don't know a history of being abusive
stuff like that would be what you would
be trying to screen for like maybe
indicators that psychologists would say
could lead to future spousal abuse stuff
like that so say like someone hasn't
committed abuse yet but they have
psychologists who have screened them and
said this person is a high risk
candidate we should be able to restrict
their gun access so you wanna so you
want to put the weight of gun access and
that decision upon psychologists yeah I
think that science and like
psychologists and professionals who have
studied this and know the indicators for
what will lead to these mass shootings
should be the ones who are deciding who
can actually have access to these guns
and I mean you can make it as a
bipartisan as you want you can have
conservative psychologists and liberal
psychologists on the panels I think that
psychologists being part of that process
is critical because we need to do
something unless these gun gun deaths
are going to continue with in the United
I think a quick look at the pooling of
college professors in colleges in
general would show that I didn't say
college professors I just said
professionals like oh yeah but but now
trust becomes it kind o unless you're
saying none exist or you're somehow
advocating that the field of psychology
is partisan then I don't think II have a
point do is it field of psychology
partisan yes it the field of psychology
is based on what
do you I mean it's based on if they
start pulling right there's there's men
but the least I mean the two points to
that would be one look-alike across the
United States the least partisan college
field is business of which liberal
college professors outnumber
conservative college professors that's
because facts have a liberal bias but
when we're talking about we can have a
partisan bipartisan panel deciding this
and regardless you already agreed that
screening for mental illness is a
critical part of gun regulation how
that's implemented is a different debate
before I do that can change the way
degree we also do you want to talk about
a different regulation so do you know
what happened in Australia we've begun
buyback program yes okay so what
happened with all the mass shootings
occurring within that country after
they're done buyback program they went
on at the exact same rate that they were
going down before no no no mass
shootings there has not been a single
mass shooting within Australia since
their gun buyback program no I'm nothing
but the like general homicide of a mass
shooting whatever the standard
definition that Pew Research because
there's a lot of studies out there and
you you agreed that the homicide rate is
going down in Australia breath it was
going down the exact same rate before
the bomb okay so the homicide rates
going down and we haven't had a single
mass shooting according to data from Pew
Research you can look at what however
they're defining that but clearly it's
done me it's had the effect needed of
stopping these mass shootings right no I
don't agree okay wait so what's what's
the negative of the gun buyback program
well the negative of the gun buyback
program is first of all you have to
decide what kinds exactor gonna be
buying that which I can quite imagine
that because all of the guns that are
currently legal I would highly advocate
art should be legal flyback for handguns
buyback for hangers
okay so you've now so if you might have
a buyback for hangers would you also be
okay with a buyback for rifles things
that aren't defined as handguns I I'm
just
I'll just argue handguns right now
because you can argue rifles have like
aspects of hunting and stuff and that's
just a different territory no one uses
rifles and mass shootings it's mostly a
fully automatic well that's that's not
that's also not active right for the
rifles are
all righty of them are done would like
Matic that's automatic Wow would you
mind doing me a favor could you hold the
microphone for a second all right go
ahead you guys continue good so I'm
passing my notepad and pen go ahead
continue all right but if you're gonna
make counter points to me you better
make it to me a non-traditional person
absolutely sorry continued gun buyback
program we saw a massive decrease in the
amount of shootings have Aaron the mass
shootings are happening within the
country so that's a good effect so too
were there any negative effects of the
gun buyback program in Australia yes
people have their weapons confiscated
okay and what's the negative of people
having their weapons confiscated well in
this case of the United States our
second a great defense okay no no but I
asked her like a negative what is the
tangible negative of people having their
comebacks I said tangible positive no
mass shootings now you have to tell me a
tangible negative it reduces people's
ability to define okay so do you know
how many people are able to stop mass
shootings with a gun because you're
saying people will defend themselves I
want I want to know how many people stop
mashing on this is a question you know
you can't do this you have to let the
guy answer the question I understand
that this works and you know pivoting so
I just yeah I know I know you're
pivoting but that's no that's right
questions pivot it's about question
pivot no I feel like actually let's just
make sure if you ask a question ya know
nobody answer the question yes because
again this is kind of like attack and
defend where he stated a position and be
affirmative yeah no no you're you're
looking to change his mind
yes right you're not looking to just go
right that that that that that yeah say
that he's wrong you're right okay go
ahead ask your question and then you can
answer how many people stopped mass
shootings with a gun I don't know the
exact statistic will not probably number
of people stop that soon
do you think that it's a lot or what do
you think it is I know that for general
crime there are statistics that say that
on the lowlanders as many as 400,000
times of stop with defensive use of
handguns in the United States sure
that's a wide estimate because it's
harder to find but the lowland is
significantly higher than the number of
murders caused by okay well by when
we're talking about mass shootings it's
one every 30 years is stopped by an
individual handgun sorry my bad
where like I in America and in the
whenever every one every 30 years the
stop of the hand okay so with that gun
in general my they got in general okay
so you talked a lot about what we talked
a lot about mass shootings yeah I'm
unfortunately not 100% familiar with the
mass shooting statistics in Australia
but I was like talk about the United
States well I just bring that up as an
example of where they implemented the
program and it worked right all right so
I would like to talk about one planet
first of all let's get back to the night
scene
sure and let's get back to tumors
because the truth is that mass shootings
actually constitute a very very very
very small portion of the number of gun
murders in the United States sure yeah
um so the problem I have been with a gun
buyback program is that it's not
actually a private because the God did
this beep apparently yeah the government
uses their money to buy your guns best
yeah where did the government get that
money from taxpayers so I paid the
government to buy my gun back yeah
Alessa which means they're not buying my
gun back they're just taking my gun back
yeah and I'm not arguing this from an
economic point of view are marketing for
a benefits of society as in like murder
rates for mass shootings point of view
right and like sure you can like argue
that I guess the wealthy people over
like the top 1% are gonna pay a larger
portion of the gun buyback but I mean
like I'm fine with that if you are huh I
mean no I wouldn't be fine with that but
if you wants anyway
so you talk about mass shootings can we
talk a little bit about what about just
done yeah burgers because she goes again
with mashing if you want to say why yeah
our mass shootings are very small
portion yeah so how do you know how many
murders that are in the United States
the committed to commit with with guns
no I just know that the number has been
going down consistently it's it's about
it's it's wrong it's time to twenty
thousand okay I the number of the murder
of deaths from guns is about forty but
about about half of that is suicide
so I think we could put suicide suicide
yeah we can talk about suicides later
kind of drifting it so yeah the vast
majority of those are committed with
handguns okay yeah the vast majority so
would you propose a system fine backhand
gun yeah that's what I proposed
initially okay so you're not so would
you fly back and so right now you buy
back would you also buy back right this
no I said before I think rifles have
other uses and they're not used to
commit crimes like you're talking about
or in mass shootings as much as like
handguns or like some about a magical
weapons so you're not ok with people on
hang on no because air I mean we can
talk about ar-15 air ban is right sure
but we're talking about like I I guess
we can talk about like specific types of
rifles I think we're getting a little
off in the weeds here the point I'm
trying to make here is that you're not
really advocating for a five- sensation
or any common-sense gun control in order
to get rid of to get rid of these types
of guys you really want to get rid of
all guns right I want to do whatever is
going to most decrease the amount of
crime within the United States and
decrease the amount of shootings
occurring because something needs to be
done otherwise they're going to kill you
I would say Thomas getting all going to
be a way to do that yeah I mean I ended
that Mutina
what happened in the UK we learnt the
buyback program I imagine the homicide
rates kept going down really after the
UK banned handguns the next two years
the number of penguin s rose and now
since then the number of stabbings and
knife deaths has just risen okay but how
many people are killed within one
stabbing versus one shooting right so
when you're talking about like say like
if stabbings is increasing or like
number people being hit by a truck is
increasing that those are much like less
occuring things and then shootings and
those are also okay I think we're
getting a little bit off the beam here
let's go back final kind of closing
statements I think what's really
important here is the nature of
something right the essence of thing
we're talking about the Second Amendment
so you've talked about kind of okay
handguns and then maybe rifles and then
maybe these sort of background checks
which maybe I support maybe I don't the
essence of the Second Amendment is what
do you - both fundamentally disagree I'm
seeing that you both fundamentally
disagree on the precept of the Second
Amendment if that's the case then a lot
of this is just mental gymnastics and
pointless so closing statements your
view on the Second Amendment and why you
are pro Second Amendment
the reason why I'm pro second man is
because I don't believe it's the
government's duty to protect us from
each other right I believe that when you
when you take with there's an idea right
and in your line of going off there you
go to your family there are social
institutions for the church or whoever
it is local state federal government the
federal government chef very little to
do with anything
and I'm not comfortable with leaving
I don't think that they'd have the
wisdom I don't think that they have the
mental wherewithal to decide that sort
of thing okay good wrap it up okay Shawn
yeah and so I would take almost the
exact off as a point is that one of the
primary goals of government is to defend
ourselves that's like one of the is to
protect the American citizens is to
protect us from each other is this make
yeah but it's protecting American
citizens from foreign and domestic
enemies and it's to keep us safe and
that is one of the primary goals of the
US government and so I think that
anything that we can show that can
tangibly decrease the amount of violence
and tangibly save lives should be
implemented because that's what the
founding fathers fathers wanted is a
constitution that changes with the times
and adapts to what is best for the
people of this country okay great thank
you guys very much appreciate it thank
you can I sit down with you for a second
Mike right yeah Mike all right how did
you feel that conversation I felt I
wasn't as familiar with the exact effect
of the Benton by back as specific to
mass shootings as I wish I could have
been right so would you say that he was
a he did pretty well he did do very well
yeah okay it does surprise you um no I
knew it I was I was going up against
somebody new at their head okay now the
reason I asked you and I don't want to I
don't want you at all to feel like I'm
throwing you under the bus at all but
the reason you said I asked you
beforehand because you were going meat
meat you really really wanted to end it
in my experience the people typically
who are most eager to step in and debate
our Park probably the people who should
pump the brakes a little bit okay and
wait let me tell you something before I
sit down every single time here I almost
have to go change my pants sometimes I
go to the bathroom to throw up because I
get so nervous because I feel as though
I might be ill prepared or I feel as
though I may not be able to present a
watch that the most logical argument I
feel as though there may be something
that I'm not anticipating right and I
believe in anticipating that yeah I
think didn't seem like you were nervous
coming in at all you were really
chomping at the bit to come in I was
nervous I think a few hours ago but as I
kind of settled in and yeah I got rid of
that and in my experience people who
really just want to get in and mix it up
don't tend to be the most prepared I
think you both had some valuable
arguments I think that you probably
could have presented some more valuable
arguments if there was a little bit more
of a hell
the fear and healthy respect for someone
on the outside of you and I say this as
someone who would largely agree with
your view on the Second Amendment but
maybe going for do you think going
forward you might take a different tact
absolutely and maybe also get I think
what we saw a lot of here was there
wasn't a lot of dead air space and since
he just kept going going going enormous
really listening to each other you know
what I mean you were both kind of going
rat-tat-tat-tat and a lot of points were
missed but man I do appreciate the ball
that it takes to sit here out in the hot
Sun all day doing this thank you Mike
thank you brother I appreciate it thank
you Mike
Sean yeah why don't you come up here
because I don't even hung up a bit hi
Sean nice to meet you so I know because
earlier you were really pretty pretty
zealous and wanting to uh I wanted to
talk with me okay I like your she might
you ain't sitting kind of do you mind
moving forward and sure getting close to
the microphone here I'll use my handheld
mics to try and help you out but how did
that conversation with Michael I think
I'm pretty well I enjoy talking to him I
think like when you mentioned that I was
interrupting a little bit too much I
think I was getting a little overzealous
with the cxo I probably could have
waited a second yeah this isn't whenever
I feel felt like I heard that he was
trying not to answer a question I
interrupted by noise Jenna no no I I
appreciate you recognizing it did get a
little bit heated and I feel like you
guys were talking over each other or
them with each other would you agree
yeah okay so you want you set and you
really want to what just happen here
that's embarrassing don't worry happens
to lots of guys happens with you they're
failures as men and I was sitting I
really did not want to jump in at all
I am Pro Second Amendment this seemed
like it was a subject that you really
wanted to come in on that you were
passionate about yeah do you kind of
sort of taking some notes at one point I
don't want to be unfair I want to see
first how you thought that conversation
went because I just sat down with Mike
and asked that what would you change
about it if you could go back like I
said maybe during like CX whenever I
asked a question just pulling back and
allowing
time to respond yeah because I shouldn't
probably shouldn't have tried to like
intervene when I thought he was pivoting
I should have just allowed him to go on
and then maybe restated the question or
something Wilshire a better tactic I
don't know if you heard what I just told
Mike yeah
but often in my experience the people
who are the most oh we need to get it
closer
hold on one second here damn it Wade
No
better often people who are the most I
would say sort of overzealous chocolate
depicting in the microphone people who
are the least prepared I like it boasted
I am always very braced I get very
scared before any kind of public
speaking
yeah I get scared before I come on do
this fake I don't want to get shot or
stabbed you know and that's always a
part of the equation
we also carry on oh that's right yeah
which I don't know where you line up on
that but I also want to make sure the
arguments are at least as close to
airtight as I can get them I always want
to make sure that I'm not because I'm
not only representing my point of view
we're often representing the points of
view of our political bill right and we
don't want to misrepresent them um you
were really chomping at the bit to get
him to bake here - so were you nervous
or you really thought you had this in
the bag I mean sure you know you're
always nervous with whether or not you
know enough or whether they'll bring up
something that you haven't heard of
before and it's kind of just like and I
mean you have to just kind of get past
that in order public speak like you were
saying like be able to compose yourself
and just put yourself forward so I agree
with that yeah do you speak publicly a
lot do you do you argue with people a
lot um I did debate throughout high
school I'm currently pre-med so I don't
do a lot of that anymore mostly just
science stuff okay organic chemistry
which is a lot less fun than getting to
debate people but you seem pretty
experienced in it you seem pretty
confident and doing it sure yeah I enjoy
it okay and would you say that you've
done that quite a bit and would you say
that most people probably would describe
you as somebody who's articulate would
your friends probably like I don't get
into it with Sean he knows what he's
talking about my friends are all in
debate too so they enjoy getting into it
but typically speaking you probably when
it comes to a conversation like this
among friends or on campus you're
probably the more qualified or more
capable general that's what I see it
okay yeah so would you would you I mean
you guys see that [ __ ] yeah the reason I
said is because I see some problems with
that to just kind of like I was talking
with Mike where he came and I think he
thought he was a little more prepared
than he was yeah I think you being very
intelligent I can tell being supremely
confident allows you to get away with
some not only sort of logical fallacies
and knowing that you were doing it
deliberately
but you were quoting some facts and
statistics that just aren't true and I
didn't want to say anything I didn't
want to tip the scales there but I think
that sometimes if you go wrecked at that
you fired off don't necessarily call you
on and that is what I saw there would
you would you go back and think of
anything that maybe you said that may
not have been necessarily entirely
accurate that someone is formidable of
an opponent as maybe yourself might have
called you on I mean I don't the one
primary thing that I said that was
incorrect was when he said do you want
would you restrict rifles and my instant
go-to is no because I was just thinking
hunting and stuff but as he rightly
pointed out ar-15s would be a
semi-automatic and I would be in favor
of banning those so maybe like when he
asked that question taking a step back
and thinking about it for a moment have
been good part online and not just kind
of being reactionary I actually
appreciate that you recognize that
because you actually said that there are
no mass shootings using rifles yeah yeah
no I realized when you point out that
the air 15 was classify was like oh yeah
and the semi-automatic weapons but it's
an interesting argument because yes the
vast majority of crimes are often
committed with handguns right yeah and
typically the anti-gun look I want to
get rid of guns that being said there
have been mass shootings committed with
rifles true yeah so that was only you
said and I was sitting there going oh I
thought he was going to call you on that
he didn't it's not accurate
no yeah something else that you started
off and I just said it's because this
might change the landscape you should
have a conversation with Skype a little
more I'm not trying to sandbag and you
can follow any questions at me you guys
started off one of the first things you
talked about was that there are no
mental background checks yeah yeah
that's not true right now if you talk
about going into someone's medical
history so in other words if you want to
process what I was talking to say
firearm they get access to all of your
personal in front of medical records
that's been said have you have you ever
purchased a firearm no I have it okay so
you don't what the form looks like no ok
I've run a quick search and you'll see
it should it actually asked if you've
been adjudicated mentally defender right
and so there is an official standard
bearer love mentally defective
ion yeah so I think that if you'd have
called then you could have had a
different conversation you saying it's a
sliding scale that I think psychologists
should determine that not a court of law
right but one yeah so when we when we
talk about that like you were saying
that I said psychologists should
determine that I think that they should
go into the actual medical records and
determine whether or not someone has
been showing indicators toward that type
of behavior as opposed to just being
tried and convicted of like as you said
having like on their legal transcript by
mentally or I was the exact time you
said educate I think I think the term is
adjudicated mentally
yeah adjudicated mentally defective so I
think that that doesn't catch people who
have like for example be giving
indicators of domestic abuse in the past
but a psychologist on the other hand
would which is why I was arguing for
more extensive background sure
so like Minority Report and asking
people removing their rights before they
commit a crime no so not removing their
rights therefore you send a crime it's
going to be taking away their access
just weapons that they can use to kill
people right or to come form a film any
please
well yeah because so far they've
committed crimes yeah because when
you're talking about live domestic abuse
cases it's not a crime until it happens
and you want to catch that before it
happens and so you're not gonna give
somebody who's showing all these
indicators for domestic it so let me ask
you so what you're proposing is looking
for indicators that someone might commit
a violent crime and removing their
access to firearms before they committed
yes how is that not Minority Report
because in Minority Report they were
like they were pressing people who but
based on like whether or not they would
commit a crime not saying oh you can't
have a gun if you're gonna commit crime
I think the movie Minority Report would
have been very different if they said oh
you're going to commit a crime here I'm
just like not gonna give you an ar-15
right those people who are gonna commit
murder if you take away the gun they
decide to run a cooking show I mean yes
so if something else he has a shooting
something else you said how many people
stopped mass shooting so that wasn't you
said no one stopped mass shootings with
guns I think you said one one every
thirty yeah those are Mother Jones ran
that study it was not right okay so a
couple of things here and I just say
it's because you know these are things
where if you're talking with someone who
knows what they're talking about they're
gonna call you on it right I mean if you
can argue the Mother Jones study that
crunch the numbers within the United
States but I'm just citing yeah I can
tell you very clearly why it's wrong but
first off how many people stopped
because this isn't really a change my
mind at this point this was just you
know I just heard so many things or
facts I think I thought at the very
least in the beginning we did have a
little bit of good change my mind where
he agreed that like looking at people
with mental health more careful sure I
think a little bit was predicated on the
idea that there isn't already
necessarily a mental background I think
that's one of those things that I think
you know you're smart enough and I don't
think you know that there's already a
question on your background check but
you said you didn't know write that ask
if you've been mental
no no no I didn't know that user without
saying there's no mental background
check and because you are intelligent
because you come across very
authoritative he kind of accepted it
wholesale yeah that was kind of an
advantage there even so sure I was just
familiar with what the proposal was I
wasn't familiar with I guess the current
status said but there's your legal but
the proposal still stands it could be
further you know think it's
disrespectful view from no no okay to
make sure yeah so okay well thank you
before yes how many bills stop mass
shootings he didn't have that number you
know it's it's hard to know exactly how
many mass shootings are stopped right
yeah because we have an estimate even if
you look at the estimate according I
think to the FBI and CDC between half a
million to 3 million defensive uses of
firearms each year yeah and it's very
hard to measure because more often not
the firearm is simply brandished it
stops a violent crime yeah right so we
don't know how many of those crimes
stopped would be qualified as mass
shootings and this is moving I believe
mass shooting is three or more or it's
four or more depending on the country so
in other words out of the five hundred
to three million we don't know how many
mass shootings will be stopped but you
did say that one in 30 years that comes
from Mother Jones right um are you
familiar with Southern when Springs okay
that happened right here in Texas not
far from here just in San Antonio yeah
probably familiar with well the guy was
shooting up a church
yeah and the man stopped him with an
ar-15
he was an NRA certified instructor
that's happened yeah and they're 30 okay
but they're far more in that you can
point to other examples of church
shootings being stopped you can point to
other examples I mean I pointed to one
right so we I pointed one this other one
Springs was also a church shooting I
believe in Georgia recently you can find
it like I mean I mean you're listening a
study but sure 130 years is just not AG
and and just taking it on when you're
talking about that you're not to mention
by the way we would have to say how many
mass shootings are stopped by every
single mass shooting a police officer
[ __ ] of a fire that's why when you were
asking me before am I completely guess
the second then I was like well we have
to like discuss whether or not we should
allow people who like police officers
numb obviously and then like maybe
former military of training in it who
have already been mentally screened
stuff like that sure yeah it's more than
one in 30 and I think it would have to
breathe it I would love to see your
mother Jones source yeah and and just
when talking about
number of mass shootings that are
stopped by the gun violence I think that
it's also important to point out that we
don't know whether or not those were
actually like stopped by the gun being
pulled or not or like whether that you
just had a person like break into a
house with a gun who's going to drop in
and not going to shoot anybody and
someone like ran out and he runs out of
that sure I think yeah I think we both
agree that out of the five hundred to
three million defensive uses of firearms
which are hard to track each year
probably more likely that they're
significantly more than one in thirty
minutes add a caveat to my stay with a
caveat to all of them that it's hard
work but I'm saying that that would be
the caveat but if we're saying half a
million to 3 million defensive use of
the firearms each year they typically
say around 2 million is probably the
most accurate number sure let's call it
11 let's call 1.5 and split it down the
middle if we're going to say 1.5 million
defensive uses a firearm probably much
more likely that even more than one in
thirty mass shootings or stopped each
day and I would if I was taking this
position on like legislation say I would
say the right police were the ones who
should have stopped this and not the
individual in the house sure it was like
you you shouldn't I don't think act as
an executioner well the there were no
police there and the man stopped it he
was on his way to go shoot other people
and someone Springs for example like I
was a Stephen Wilford hero then you did
say you talk about psychologists yes
okay so you asked if psychology is
partisan you don't believe in it
I'm argue sure that academia has a
left-leaning vice but I don't think the
study of psychology is parties well
because you said that facts have a
liberal bias yeah yeah come on you were
scoring points in there and I think you
were doing that to try to intimidate him
a little bit yeah I mean that's that's a
line right facts of a liberal bias but
like the underlying idea behind that is
just that the reason that academia is
left-leaning is that like the facts are
lining up oh god and that's why people
are so III do
I do believe that psychology is
politicized it is a partisan let me ask
you this when you talk about a panel of
psychologists tell not just a national
panel or an International Committee of
psychologists I mean we're just talking
about the United States here right
second amendments to the Australian gun
buyback right so that's an example it
wouldn't be international kissers I mean
there is international governing bodies
but the US doesn't really have to follow
this by any like we can pretty much do
what we want right so I'm more speaking
like the second matter yeah exactly and
I think that when looking at the second
moment we should see what works best so
it should be only American psychologists
you know there should be an
international input committee whichever
whichever one reduces crime the most
okay well the reason I ask this is
because psychology is an international
practice right if you look at what is
determined in psychology its determinant
internationally not just nationally so
who's right
it's a psychologist who's right is it
the American psychologist or what is
right so an example once right the DSM
for the dsm-5 what would be correct the
latest findings on in psychology okay so
like what would be the reason for gender
dysphoria being changed that's 2014
dsm-5 gender dysphoria being put on the
DSM I think it was because I am it was
just like making a more nuanced point on
what they did they took it off yeah this
for you yeah if I'm not mistaken you
can't call it gender dysphoria anymore
yeah it could be it does get to be like
making I think it's making more newest
nuanced blanks on mental illnesses for
example they talk about like autism used
to be a single diagnosis or lion and the
Asperger's was a separate diagnosis in
the DSM form they change it in the v to
be a spectrum right autism spectrum
disorder so I think it's just like they
add layers of nuance on it and find that
things like gender dysphoria or maybe
misunderstood or not nuanced enough so
they move it into different categories
in the new DSM was like things you just
did you just refer to transgenders it's
mental illness is that how you would
refer to it you just said they careful
in discussing mental illness when I
mentioned gender dysphoria I just wanna
make sure hankie gender dysphoria was
categorized
the onus is on anymore because what I'm
saying is probably disseminated okay so
it's a lucky thing so what is considered
the was considered mentally almost a now
it's not correct now transgenderism as a
concept sure yeah okay so it wasn't none
Danny just mentioned for autism was kind
of an umbrella catch-all now the
spectrum right okay so like so let me
ask you this really well let me ask you
this is important because you say is
psychology partisan yeah so a
transgender at the time of the dsm-4
can't purchase a firearm by your logic
now they can no because I never said
everyone in the DSM can't purchase a
firearm well let's say that was
considered a mental illness was
conservative airman I said psychologists
should look at indicators for violence
transgenderism in the DSM Corps isn't an
indicator for violence it was an
indication or deter in the DSM court
said that people 42 percent of them to
to assign right it's the biggest
indicator you could possibly have any
demographic of people transgender
suicide rate yeah then I would argue
that you should have access to a handgun
because that's what's most used in
suicides in fact a different study that
I mean good access to shotguns no but
when we're talking about handguns
specifically when people have access to
handguns they're much more likely to
commit suicide just by getting access to
that handgun than someone without a who
probably wouldn't go through with it so
that's another reason to be a if that
was the case you'd think the United
States would have you think that the
United States has an abnormally high
suicide rate do they I don't know they
don't not compared to gun control
countries but again my point here as you
mentioned he's mentioned you said
psychology is not partisan but it is
it's my point for example transgenderism
is still consider gender dysphoria in
other countries okay so consider body
dysmorphia science research institutes
and that we're on the cutting edge of
psychology currently okay then I would
argue that we have better gun rights
laws in any other country we're on the
cutting edge of that and then go and you
rattle off more than any other few facts
that's actually not true do not have the
most gun deaths of any country no that's
actually not true developed country I
can add a caveat I mean like obviously
I'm sure there's a recent like subset
around
well I wouldn't include them no because
they're not developed right would you
have different you have different levels
of development industrialization right
that's really fair that makes it as far
as mashing things I think last last time
they ran the the numbers Norway and
France were higher as far as mass
shootings so our suicide actually a lot
of these Scandinavian countries in Japan
have higher suicide rates again you
could go through and go kind of assume
that I'm wrong in fact check me on all
this but I the main things that you went
through where you said there no mental
health background checks
there are said mass shootings don't use
rifles they do you said five and up five
thousand to two million are defended
there are more than one one mass
shooting the defeated by gun every
single year let alone every decade and
he said that psychology is not partisan
and he just sort of accepted it I don't
think that any of those things are
correcting the reason I says it's
because you are so you're such a smart
guy like I can see that you are
unbelievably sharp and people and I've
seen this too right I'm slightly above
the bell currently average the bell
curve as far as intelligence I'm not as
smart as you only make a pretty good
podcast I don't know about that yeah it
gets me pumped up because I disagree
with these oh really
yeah picture punching me in the face
well hopefully after this now you'll say
oh he wasn't that bad of a guy
that being said people can fall into
their own traps and this is also reason
why I don't believe that hyper
intellectuals for the only people in
charge of making policy you know
sometimes even captain you need a Kirk
not necessarily a Spock because
sometimes people get into this rhythm
when they are so smart they're generally
the smartest person in the room and I
believe that you generally are people
don't call you on some things that are
simply factually inaccurate now I think
you made a lot of compelling arguments
but I think if you remove the factual
inaccuracies to some of your arguments
they start to fall apart and that was
what I most noticed but people would
watch that and I think would certainly
say that you you performed very very
well and I would watch that and say so
and I think that you would be a
formidable opponent for anyone and I
completely agree with your point that
tying up arguments and debating with
people like this and figuring out like
where you should be more specific with
things or worry any more research is
extremely important to the public
discourse in general so I appreciate
this all right Thank You Sean very much
I appreciate so you wouldn't want to ban
us from school you know
everybody is very nice I hope that you
guys understand this is not designed to
stoke violent protests this is not
designed to be a gotcha it's not
designed to take people out of context
or to just create some kind of a
compilation video what you guys did
today by and large it was mostly
productive civil I think everyone
gleaned something from these
conversations that's what we're seeking
to do and I really appreciate that you
guys stepped up to the task even though
I know some of you were disappointed
that it was you guys having the
conversations and not me I really do
appreciate it and we hope to be back
soon guys thank you so much now there
are plenty more student editions I've
changed my mind coming your way as well
as traditional installments stay
subscribed notified and as always join
it letter of credit comm / mug club
[Music]
drinking from my mug in a button-down
how often do you see this never so do me
a favor and yourself click one of these
videos playing in one of these boxes
here or a subscribe hit the notification
bell also because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot if you really
want to support the show join my club if
you don't then there's no helping you